[Music]
hey
hi hello everybody my name is markiplier
chico hop on up here good girl
hey how's it going am i even in friend i
have no idea i'm gonna assume no
stay oh
okay so uh quick update
um i finally have been able to settle
back in i know i got back in town
what are you doing chica are you okay
you okay are you good
all right chica's comfy you're a cutie
cutie patootie and i love you hi
how's it going now you may have noticed
that the videos over the past week have
been super sporadic which is kind of
weird considering i've been back
in town for a full week but last week i
was working
on a lot of different projects that
don't actually have anything to do with
videos
and also i was doing collabs with people
uh
i can tell you about one of them rhett
and link i'm going to be on good
mythical morning
this wednesday actually uh we did some
cool stuff there and i did another
collab recently that i don't know if i
can talk about yet
and then i did one more where i did some
vocals for another random encounters
musical
uh if you haven't seen it it's the five
nights at freddy's stuff that we did
five nights at freddy's the musical the
big like five part series that they
created
uh so i i've done a lot of stuff with
them in the past including like resident
enos and things like that
but i've also uh we're working on the
the cuphead musical and i do a voice in
that one now that one's not going to
come out for a couple
months but it's just really cool because
this year
i have a ton of new things that i want
to do
and i always say that i want to do new
things but this year especially
i'm kind of committed to allowing myself
to be in the right mindset not only to
make whatever i want to make but also
allowing myself not to get bogged down
on the things that don't really matter
when it comes to making videos because
i've been doing this for about six years
now i you know i've run the gambit of
the emotions of like oh this is new and
exciting too
oh i missed the old days too oh you've
changed markiplier how could you do this
to us
you know i i've run the gambit of all
those different emotions and i'm to the
point
and i said this last week where i i'm to
the point where i'm in a really good
space i feel a lot happier about
creating things
and i feel a lot more comfortable with
experimenting about
the types of things that i can do so uh
it's it's gonna be basically in my mind
what i've come up with is
this year is going to be the year of
very weird videos because one of the one
of the things that i always do is i'm
i'm always inconsistent
uh in pretty much everything i do in
life i'm inconsistent to the point
of ridicule i am
i am just so absolutely all over the
place in everything that i do
that no one can really peg down what to
expect
next and and that's something that i
really want to embrace this year because
last year was the uh last year was like
the the year of doing a lot of big
team projects where i had uh all of us
working on a date with markiplier you
know markiplier tv
who killed markler a lot of big projects
this year
i want to execute a lot of very small
ideas very quickly
because i feel this i feel this urge
to like do random [ __ ] all the time
i have this urge and i may actually do
it
uh where i want to do a 24-hour
livestream that's not for charity it's
just for me to try to learn a skill in
24 hours and live stream the whole
process
and just get the emotional gambit of
starting it knowing failure
failing more getting desperate losing
all hope and then at the end like in the
23rd hour
actually making some progress at this
skill and i have no i have no idea how
it's going to go
or even if i could do it but it's just
you know it's just going to be a lot of
fun
this year i i think anyway you know i've
been doing this so long that you guys
have been with me for this wild
ride where it's been both an emotional
journey and also a ridiculous journey
when you really think about it in the
whole aspect of what i've been doing
but i never want to stop making new
things
i i've said it before but i run
exclusively on
[ __ ] you energy where if someone tells
me that i can't do something
i will go out of my way to make sure i
can do that one thing or at least
try my damnedest at that one thing if
someone tells me that i
can't i print out a picture of their
face and i punch it repeatedly
and then do that thing that they said i
couldn't do i operate
under the premise that i don't know what
i can't do
but no one else gets to define what i
can't do except myself
and i'll never stop trying new things
until i
find the one thing that makes me really
excited and then the next day that might
be gone and i'm on to something new
uh that's what this year is really going
to be about i want to do more collabs i
want to do more
challenges i want to do more random
[ __ ] i want to do more
like going to weird places to experience
weird different things
you know i want to do so much more
and uh yeah i mean that's it
that's pretty much it because it's so
it's so easy for me to go like
i have this grand sweeping thing and
this is the way things are gonna be now
but that's not what it's about
you know that's never been what it's
about it's not about
me like trying to reach this new
pinnacle of greatness it's just about me
every day waking up and being like what
do i want to make today
what do i want to create today what do i
want to try to do today
and so long as i can approach every
single day with that mindset
i'll always know that i'm moving forward
in life i'll always know that i'm
conquering like the blockades that i put
up in my mind i'll always know that
i don't have to be chained down to any
one core concept
because if you allow yourself to become
chained up to one thing then
you you get this in like numbing
fear of losing everything you know
you become chained to these obligations
that you don't really have
but in the end those don't matter all
that matters is
do you feel like you accomplished
something new today
do you feel like you've chipped away at
a big project today do you feel like
you've moved forward
in your life today plan for the future
and
reach the goals that you have but also
just tackle each day as it comes
and that's what i want to do this year i
don't want to really have grand sweeping
plans this year i don't have
any huge goal that i have i'm already a
big youtuber i could be
a bigger youtuber someday but all i know
is that today
i want to create something different
than i wanted to create yesterday
and so long as i chase that feeling like
i'll always be making new stuff and i'll
always be surprising you with what i can
make
and uh it may be inconsistent it may be
consistent sometimes
it may be a series that i'm doing now it
may be a van vlog that i'm doing later
but
it's all going to be fun and it's all
going to be
worth it in the end because
i'll know that i'm improving that's all
i can really help
so anyway i just wanted to quickly uh
catch you up on everything i've got
other stuff that i'm going to be working
on today
i've got other ideas that i'm going to
be executing soon and it's just going to
be a lot of fun so thank you everybody
so much for watching
thank you for being here with me and as
always
i will see you in the next video
bye-bye okay bye
[Applause]
okay now bye bye
now